and the rest of this family to the baby
god to all of those who helped raise
dante lord i pray that ahead of our
celebration
of life on tomorrow god that you will
minister to us throughout this memorial
that your holy spirit will greet us
with the holy kiss in this place god i'm
praying that
through dante's life some others some
other young men
and some other young women will be saved
i'm praying that this community
lord will receive a win the freshman
of heaven this is our prayer and this is
our plea
for this family
[Music]
the family of dante wright
we are so grateful that you have opened
up your cathedral
for us to give the most
respect for homegoing to this young man
who
was taken from us much too soon
i'm attorney ben trump and before we
introduce my mentor i want to have
my co-counselor's attorney tony ramon
nucci
and attorney jeff stones come and join
me
at the podium as we make a plea
attorney lucy is one of the finest civil
rights lawyers
in america who has from chicago illinois
and attorney jeff stomps is
one of the finest civil rights lawyers
who hails from the state of minnesota
and tony and i
reverendo just set foot in the state of
minnesota
without checking in with jeff storms
you know the way dante
was killed thrusts this manner
bishop drum right into the
national media
and when people watch the video
even though he was the first
child of aubry and katy
wright became
a child of america
people all over america saw their child
in dante known but by the grace of god
caitlyn aubry it could be their child
and so as tony and jeff and i
go try to get justice
for the family of dante
wright we remember dr king's words
when he said it is the talent
that asked the question is it safe
he said expediency asked the question
is it politically correct then he said
family asked the question
is it popular but then every now and
then
conscious ask the question
is it right and dr king
concluded there comes a time when one
must take a position
that's either popular nor politically
correct
or not even safe but reverend
dr king concluded there comes a time
when one must take a position
because their conscience tells them it
is the right
thing to do when you watch that video
your conscience tells you it is the
right thing to do
to stand up for dante right
to speak up for dante wright
and to fight for dante wright
because if we don't fight for dante
we can't expect nobody else to fight for
dante
so we're standing here making a solemn
pledge
caving and operating to all the right
family
you won't be fighting alone we will be
fighting with you
in and outside the courtroom
to make sure that there's accountability
and we brought a person with us
who helps from new york city who is now
a
lawyer but he is as gifted
of a strategist and articulate
as any lawyer i've ever met he
helped george floyd's family
through their journey of justice and so
many other families
through their journey of justice
bishop howe he didn't think in robbery
when
i told him about
what happened and reverend tune and here
and i'm talking he said we got to be
there
for dante smith he never wavered not
vacillated regardless of what the
police narrative was when they tried to
assassinate dante's character
he said that could have been any of our
children who they shot on a minor
traffic citation
so i'm so grateful to have my
mentor who always answers the veil
our national civil rights leader in
america
today the reverend al
johnson to give him some prayers of
confidence
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you attorney mcgraw who is the
attorney general for
us let me say this
i will say much of what i say for the
eulogy tomorrow
but i want our mankind to know
and i want the brothers and sisters
of dante know that as
we got diverted last night
for george poyle and people celebrated
all over the country
as i was crying the thing that bothered
me
was right down the road was dante wright
minnesota doesn't have the right
to talk about what it did right
until they get this right don't
tell us what you did
for george floyd and ignore what
happened
to dante rank you not going to tell me
that somebody on the force 26 years
don't know the difference between a gun
and a taste
i come from brooklyn new york i know
hoods
in the street that know a difference
between a hood
and gun at a table so i press to them
i treasure these young brothers that we
gonna fight
and don't bring me no mess about dante's
record i want to know about the police
woman's records
she shot him so don't
turn the beat around we're gonna get
this straight
and we came 11 months ago and said we
just came with the floyds
let the record show we're going to stand
with the rights
we want to get right right in minnesota
[Music]
[Applause]
i wish we could bring him back but we're
gonna make sure
we can do the next next thing we're
going to raise him up
as the example of a mother and a father
this is a family they don't need me much
to you but this couple
has stayed together and brought their
family together and for you to rob them
of their child i looked at the video
of his father teaching them how to fight
my father left out of here never taught
me nothing you don't have the right to
do that
you had a right to break katie's heart
and they didn't raise their children to
hate
they're an interracial family that
believed in harmony and love
and you brought hate into their family
and we've been running out
and getting justice
let us pray thank you bishop for letting
us
come and do this service
and i asked the public to respect the
family as they mourn
it's a lot on them that they decide to
leave let them
lead this we appreciate everybody's
condolences but this is their child this
is their brother and respect them
and give them the space they need as
they want
dear god we thank you
for giving us the strength to stand
sometimes we don't understand
why things happen and only you could
explain why
20 years life just started you
allowed this to happen but we know that
we're charged to fight for what's right
we know that we're charged to stand up
and be counted among those that don't
flinch and don't walk about
and we'll understand it better by
lord give us the strength strengthen
then crumple
sharpen his mind ready for another
battle
strengthen their family as they surround
aubry and
king to let them have the strength
to bear this pain they will never be
able to replace the hole
in their heart when dante is gone
but give them the strength to bear back
so that in doctor's name no other child
would be
told that they were just taken from us
by mistake
and we will give your name to praise and
the glory and honor shall be done
not ours these blessings
as we stand together family god bless
you
god bless you for those
family members that are wanting to leave
please feel free at this time
as we continue to open up these doors
for the rest of the community
this is our community so may god bless
you
in jesus name god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
awesome
let's see
okay
for them to have to spend this here
under these circumstances
we got to give them a wedding gift of
[Music]
justice
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you can begin checking in tomorrow at
[Music]
11.
[Music]
[Music]
chicken
[Music]
what a good job
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh